- [Narrator] There was some
kind of chemistry between us
that we absolutely
hadn't counted on.
- Did you display an early
talent for singing, or for--
- I didn't actually.
I got thrown out of the choir.
It's a ridiculous situation
to sign a contract when
you're 18 years old
and be held to it
for your entire professional career.
I used to get really, really
paranoid and after every show,
I'd have to go straight back to the hotel
and talk to no one.
- He was an English singer,
songwriter, record producer,
who rose to prominence for
his part in the duo, Wham!.
He's best known for his
work in the 80's and 90's
including hit singles,
"Last Christmas," and
"Wake Me Up Before You Go-Go."
He sold over 100 million
records worldwide.
He's George Michael
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is our personal favorite
and I'm curious to figure out which one
you guys like the best.
And as always, as George is talking,
If he says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(whooshing)
(powerful inspirational music)
- The first
mention of George Michael
in my life was by Mark Dean,
who ran this little label,
called Innervision, and he said,
"I've signed an act that
you're going to love
and they're going to huge,
and they're called Wham!."
(Wham! song)
And I said, "They're called Wham!."
He said, "Yes, they're called Wham!."
- [Narrator] They were
starting to get noticed
on the UK music scene,
but what was it about Wham!,
that made them stand out
from the competition?
- I think to be honest with you,
great songs,
and
a formula that we didn't realize we had.
These two young boys
doing this kind of Butch
Cassidy and Sundance thing,
but in a very, kind of camp way.
And I think there was
something about the fact
that it was all very obvious
that our relationship
as friends was real.
There was some kind of
chemistry between us
that we absolutely
hadn't counted on,
but the world seemed
to see pretty quickly.
- What about the business
of being what you are now?
They have the musician, the songwriter...
Did you display an early
talent for singing or for--
- I didn't actually.
I got thrown out of the choir.
- Did you?
(audience laughs)
- I was thrown out of the choir for
I think, as far as I know,
It was for talking.
And I always remember my
dad used to say to me,
Ya know, cause I used to say, "Dad...,"
back when I was like, 16, 17, 18,
and my Dad would threaten
to throw me out the house
if I didn't get a job
within a certain amount of time,
so obviously I went out and got a job,
but I was saying,
I want to be a singer.
I think I'm going to be rich and famous.
And he would say, "everybody
wants to be a pop singer,
everybody wants--"
And I would say, "No, Dad.
Everybody wants to be pop singer
when they're 12.
When they're 12.
This is my whole life.
This is what I want to do."
But, I've lost my train of thought.
(audience laughing)
- But was it to be
rich and famous your ambition?
- No, I think I had two
very, very strong ambitions
and they've always fought
against one another.
Always.
And one, was a passion for music
and an ability to
communicate through music.
And really a sense of
purpose through music.
And two, was this desire
to be-- and rich and famous is not right
because actually rich never came into it.
I actually realized about six months ago,
someone put a question to me,
and I actually realized,
that at no point during my
early life, when I was...
In all my ambitions, or
even when I started to
realize my ambitions,
at no point did it ever occur to me
that one of the byproducts
of this would be
that I could buy whatever I wanted,
or live in a big house, have a flashy car,
all the things that are very pleasant.
But It really hadn't occurred to me.
It never occurred to me.
So, I didn't want to be rich,
I just wanted to be filthily famous.
I signed that contract
and I understand the...
the premise of sanctity of contract,
but it's a ridiculous,
such a ridiculous situation.
Firstly, you are almost
always signing people
in a very vulnerable position.
I definitely was in a
very vulnerable position.
- On the first contract at the age of 18.
- Exactly. I was at the age of 18.
And many bands are signed that young.
Some are signed a little older,
but whenever they're
signed, they're desperate.
Whenever they're signed, they think
it's going to be their only chance.
But more importantly
than the,
the balance of that situation,
which is very unfair,
is the fact that,
there isn't one other industry
that operates on this basis.
If I were
an author,
and I fell out with my record company
in the way that I have,
the worst I would have
to endure was the fact
that I would have to,
that they would have the
first option on my next book,
so to I'm at two books.
It's a ridiculous situation
to sign a contract when
you're 18 years old,
and be held to it for your
entire professional career.
Why
why would any court...
uphold that situation.
The judge seems to have found, in my case,
that I reaffirmed
this contract at the given points
of my re-negotiations,
but did I really have any choice?
The choice that I had,
was to go along with that length of term,
or to do what I've done now,
which has been an incredibly
difficult process.
- The abiding fact,
obviously, to the judge
was that you had voluntarily,
and with expert advice,
signed these contracts.
- Are you talking about
the first contract,
- When all is through,
he really seems to think--
- All through, yes, I mean...
- On the one hand, we see your quandary,
but, for him the abiding fact was,
and I guess for many people,
was that you did sign them.
On balance, you decided it's
better to sign them than not.
And that's why you're left
with the consequences.
- Oh I think it, but I think
that's a very, very odd
position to take.
I think that,
in all honesty, I think that
there is more to consider
in this case than
my situation.
From my point of view,
I really, honestly do not
expect the public to have any
great sympathy for a
man who's very wealthy.
I'm in good health, I'm very wealthy and
I have a lot of public support
and I completely accept that.
I'm not looking for public sympathy.
I just don't believe that
If you are wealthy that your principles
are supposed to be null and void.
That you're not supposed to fight for...
for your principles.
All artists accept that,
have accepted for years and years,
that they get a considerably
small piece of the pie,
considering that they are the real product
and people go out and buy what they give.
But, I have to be honest,
It's never been a big problem for me.
Being paid less than other artists
has always been a problem
for me in terms of pride.
In terms of the money I was making,
I'm lucky enough to be one of the people
that sells enough records,
that I don't care.
I have a very good lifestyle,
I'm very wealthy.
I would also have to add,
I'm nowhere near as wealthy
as the tabloid press
would let you believe,
but I'm perfectly happy with
the money I've got and...
- They say 18 million.
- They say 18 million,
let's just call it a fraction.
(laughing)
Am I right?
But it's still plenty.
- Is the fraction
more than a half
between a half
and two thirds?
- I'm not telling you that.
- Alright, okay.
- I wouldn't tell the court
that, I'm not going to tell you that.
But let me put it this way,
I think I've got something
to complain about
simply because in principle it's wrong.
The end result is that I'm
still a very wealthy man,
so really, I can
understand people thinking,
he should shut his mouth,
but the principle is wrong and this case
has decided,
it's not over yet,
I emphasize it's not over yet,
but this case will decide
the future of,
of all artists in my position.
There were times in the
last five, six years,
that I was very tempted to just say,
"ya know what, forget it.
"This is too difficult,
"you're not out with
the album that you need,
"and you're driving
yourself crazy with it."
And I was,
and of course on top of that,
I was getting quite a
kicking from the press. So,
at that point in my life,
with so much going on emotionally,
being kicked about by the media,
and the press and the industry,
almost wishing,
almost wishing that my career was over,
I was almost ready to give up.
But part of my motivation,
a very strong part of my
motivation to keep going,
was that I always knew
how terrible it would look
to young gay kids that were
worried about coming out.
Not that they necessarily
see a great parallel with
someone who was outed
when they were 35, but
I think it is a very--
It would be a horrible way
to leave my career,
to leave people thinking that my sexuality
took away my market,
'cause I just knew that wasn't true.
And I felt a kind of responsibility,
not only to myself, but
to young gay people,
to say, look, because I
was so absolutely sure that
my market hadn't left me,
so I felt it really important to say,
Look, it is not damaging
if you have ability,
it is not damaging
to have the confidence to come out.
And in certain parts of life
it really doesn't matter anymore.
In certain careers it really
doesn't matter anymore.
And I think just the success
of the record this time 'round,
and I hope it's continued success
will alleviate that perception.
I'm looking forward to getting
more and more comfortable it
and my voice getting stronger and stronger
as the tour goes on.
- [Interviewer] What do you
do to prevent it from...
- Nothing.
(laughs)
- You're just lucky.
- [George] I'm just lucky. Yeah.
I have lozenges that I suck the whole day
out of paranoia,
but, no, really,
since I learned to relax about it,
I've found it much easier, actually.
I used to get really, really paranoid.
And after every show I'd have to go
straight back to the
hotel and talk to no one,
and it's so dull
and so boring and actually
led to more throat problems
because of the anxiety,
but I'm much more relaxed about it now
and my voice seems to be fine.
And I feel ready to do it.
And it also feels very honest
It feels very honest.
I would not be ready to
come out and do another
three years of a greatest hits tour.
And even though there
are some of my greatest,
quite a few of my greatest hits in this,
it's something completely different.
And that's what I need right now.
I don't want to, as I said,
I'm not really interested
in repeating experiences
again and again.
And I like to challenge myself
to improve as a vocalist and believe me,
singing with an orchestra
is one was to do it,
really, it really is.
- [Interviewer] So what
challenges do you see lie ahead?
- Well, the dance album is a challenge.
I think it will be a
challenge with the media.
But the challenge of this tour, really,
is to see what kind of singer
I can be by the end of it.
By Christmas, I think I'll see
just what my potential as a singer is
at this point in time.
And I hope I'll be a better
singer than I've ever been.
- You haven't been all that kindly handled
by the critics, have you?
- The music critics.
The bigger...
- Only the public like you.
It's the usual syndrome.
But why do you think the
critics are unamicable to you?
Why do you think they give you so much--
- I think it's exactly that.
I think it's because
we do own up to everything
that we do here.
We're very honest about
how we market ourselves.
We're probably the only band at the moment
who are totally unashamed
of being screamed at.
And I think, it's like, we do everything
that everyone else does,
only everyone else is
very subtly camouflaging
the ways of selling themselves.
And we just think, there's no reason
that you don't have to...
It's not insulting your public to do it
and to tell them you're doing it
because they enjoy it just the same way.
Marketing is marketing and image is image.
No one thinks that's really us.
I think deep down, I don't
think anybody thinks that we're
what we portray ourselves to
be in our videos or anything,
but because we make it so
obvious that we're mocking about,
I think we blow other people's cover,
and it's irritating to a lot of people.
- [Man] In another headline grabbing move,
George announced that
his next album, Patience,
will be his last record
on sale to the public,
and future releases
will be available for free download only.
- Well actually, what I said was,
It'd be available for free,
or for charitable donation
if people wanted to.
And the actual truth is
nobody donated anything,
so I've kind of withdrawn
the idea, as it were.
What I said and what I
still believe is that
in order to make my life work for me,
in an industry which is falling apart,
I think the things that I want to say,
and there's things that
I still have to say,
I think are out of place
now in the medium of pop.
So, I think I might have
to look for other avenues
in which to write.
Because, I'm not who I
was, even five years ago.
I've got some brand new ideas now
and I want them to be of some use.
I've always believed that my creativity
is with me for a reason
and that always wanting to
have a positive effect in life
with what you create is something
that is hard to give up.
Even though it'd be lovely
to be self indulgent,
I do really believe that there's a reason
that I was given this gift.
And it doesn't just
have to be in my voice.
It's about
things I want to say.
- [Interviewer] In the
breaks of this tour,
I understand that you're
recording a new album,
which is very different
from the Symphonica tour.
It's modern dance music.
How do you combine the two?
- Well, the thing is, I'm
interested in the two.
You know what I'm saying?
I've always had, I think
I'm pretty well known for
having there being a
fairly even balance in
my successes in terms of
balance and uptempo songs,
and so that's kept my
kind of lyric writing,
the lyric writing element of
what I do going constantly
'cause I'm working in my mind on that.
And this is all much more about my voice.
So, I think,
I think at my age,
to be able to have those
two things going on
and to know that they'll both be heard
to a degree is quite remarkable.
I'm thrilled about it to
have that kind of momentum
in my own brain
at this age.
- I mean, obviously you can't
come on a show like this
without mention of the
wanking in the toilet thing.
(audience laughing)
- Which wanking in the toilet thing?
Which one?
- The arresting.
- Oh, of course.
That one. Yeah. The one we've heard about.
- That one.
(audience laughing)
- And, and--
- The time I got caught you mean?
- Yeah. That one.
(audience laughing)
Possibly the last time.
(applause)
And this, this is the thing.
This is the thing, that amazingly,
the way you talk about it,
is your fantastic sound
of unapologetic about it.
And you didn't go into hiding,
you didn't sort of go draw the curtains,
Like, was it the next night,
you were out in a restaurant in L.A.
having dinner?
- Yeah, absolutely.
Well, what's to apologize for?
I'm a gay man, at the time
I was like 36 years old.
If I'm perfectly honest.
If I'm perfectly, perfectly honest,
outside of my career,
I've had a terrible run of luck that
started about 10 years ago.
I've watched a partner die,
I've watched my mother die,
just after that, I went to see a
back surgeon who told me
that if I didn't have
two vertebrae removed
within the next six months to a year,
that I could be paralyzed.
So you just learn to have
a different perspective.
I don't give a toss if people have
a real problem with me
having...
(applause)
Thank you.
I have a different perspective on life.
I've lost a lot of great things,
but I still have a lot
of incredible things
and the press doesn't
really enter in to it.
I don't care if people never
see my face in the next,
for the rest of this century.
The body of work is safe now.
If I get hit by a bus tomorrow,
people will remember what I've done
and they'll still enjoy it.
That's so lucky.
People make brilliant music all the time
that doesn't get played for 20 years
and for some reason, mine just
sits in that pocket where it does.
And such an incredible thing to
to feel that you've achieved that.
It's very possible that pop has had
the best out of me that it going to get.
Even though I want to be making
music 'till the day I die,
it's perfectly possible to say 25 years
on the charts is pretty good going
and you can't expect
to be relevant forever.
But the body of work I've done already,
five albums in 25 years,
not exactly prolific,
but I think
pretty good in terms of quality.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because my video editor,
Christina, asked me to.
Thank you for that, Christina.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know, what did George say
that had the biggest
impact on you and why.
Please leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Tuan Nguyen.
Thank you so much for picking
up 10 copies of my book
and continuing to spread the love
and gift them to other people.
I love the pictures.
Keep them coming, man.
And I appreciate all the support.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much Love. I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)